[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday july 18th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
by now it's common knowledge that
someone somewhere is after your data
advertisers want information on your
interest so they can sell you things
law enforcement might be interested in
your search history texts or location
data
hackers well they want your data to
steal things
and following the supreme court's
decision to overturn roe v wade more
people are thinking about how that data
could be used against them if they
sought an abortion we covered that a
couple weeks ago on the show so if
you're interested be sure to queue that
episode up next
but the issue of who has access to your
data and how they could use it raises
another question
who are you choosing to share it with
the answer may surprise you and it
depends a lot on what apps you have on
your phone
joining us to discuss that and how to
protect your personal data on your phone
is our personal tech columnist nicole
nguyen
hey nicole thanks for joining us hi
thanks for having me nicole let's start
with all the sensors that are used by
apps are apps limiting themselves to the
information that they need to run or are
they collecting information that
maybe might seem a little excessive if
we were to look at it it really depends
on the app we hope that apps only ask
for access and actually do access stuff
on our phone that they need to run
but some
don't and that's because they're
maybe they're free and they earn their
revenue by sending data about people who
use their app to marketers so for
example if you download a free game or
something seemingly innocuous like a
flashlight app and it's using a lot of
stuff on your phone you know you notice
that in the battery usage data analysis
that you can get in settings on your
phone that the flashlight app is one of
the top ones then
maybe double check and look into why
something
that isn't running all the time is using
so much battery
i mean these apps have been taking all
of this data for a while now but is
there an urgency to act to protect our
privacy at this moment it's sort of a
white a why not now um because
there it's so hard to reclaim your data
once it's out into the ether it's often
shared with multiple third parties and
and it's hard to track where it goes
once it's out there but there's also a
renewed interest in privacy issues
because of the supreme court's decision
to overturn roe v wade and how some of
your personal data could be sought by
courts and others in states that ban
abortion
okay so if we're trying to reduce the
amount of information collected by our
phones what is the first step we should
be taking
really limit the apps on your phone to
the apps that you use i think it's a
really good idea to regularly
audit your library for downloads that
you don't really use anymore
an expert i spoke to put it this way
every app is a potential privacy threat
and so if you're not using something
then just delete it because why have it
on your phone and
allow it access to sensors that could
potentially reveal sensitive data about
you
and also scrutinize why an app is free
or look at their privacy policy to see
if they can share or sell your data
i mean obviously they're going to be
some apps that we need to leave on our
phone or maybe there are free apps that
we just like to use so how do we limit
the information that they're gathering
both ios and android have done a pretty
good job at giving you tools to limit a
lot of these more sensitive sensors so
for example
both platforms offer the ability to turn
off location services on a per app basis
and apple allows you to set location
service access to while you're just
using the app and so that it's not
collecting that kind of data in the
background so definitely you know
monitor
data usage battery usage storage usage
of all of the apps that are on your
phone to see if any app is sucking up
more resources and look into why
and you can also look in privacy
settings in your phone and make sure
that it doesn't have access to things
that it doesn't need so for example your
astrology app probably doesn't need your
location so you can safely turn it off
because it'll still work
whether or not it has access to
gps and bluetooth you know a year or so
ago apple started asking users if they
wanted apps to track them i mean we're
talking about tracking in terms of
online activity not location but i
wonder if that's made a difference in
terms of protecting people's privacy
it's it's a great idea um apple now has
allow apps to request to track which is
a very confusing setting on your phone
disabled by default which means that if
you turn it on apps have the ability to
ask your permission to track but if you
have it turned off then
across the board apps cannot track you
across apps
it's a great first step but it doesn't
mean that app isn't collecting data as
you use the app so the tracker can't
track your movements across different
apps or across different websites but it
can still track what you're doing within
the app and share or sell that data so
it's
important also to scrutinize an app's
privacy policy on a per app basis
all right that's our personal tech
columnist nicole nowen thanks so much
for joining us nicole thanks zoe
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you